say good morning to the quarterback at
West Virginia he's will Greer I will how
are you today a man doing well thanks
for having me on what's the what's the
agenda today that practice anything else
yeah no we got a little lift cardio
stretch session here and then a little
film and little practice later on what
do you bench hello Mitch
you don't bench don't bench not a
bencher oh all right okay there's no
reason to talk to will Grier he doesn't
bench guys I mean we're bench guys will
I'm not a bench guy maybe later in life
we throw iron around here we'll that's
that's what we do and a couple of things
here the difference you show up at
practice you you're married and you have
your daughter how is life different for
you you know trying to get ready to play
football every single day oh yeah I mean
well I think you know honestly it's it's
a great it's a blessing man to have a
healthy family healthy daughter you know
my wife does a great job of making sure
that you know everything's good at home
and I can stay focused on football and I
get to do all the fun things with with
the baby and you know it's just maybe a
little added motivation you know being
the provider of a family you know I wake
up every day and I wanted everything I
can to be the best I can for them and
you know so but really other than that I
mean I'm one of the guys I you know come
in every day with the common goal that
we all have here and and work the best I
can to you know lead this team to win
win football games could you change a
diaper
and in the time that play clock expires
before it expires yeah yeah oh my school
weeks okay took a couple of weeks and
once you do it a couple times I mean
it's a
no no it's quick it depends if it's a
really dirty diaper or you know but yeah
it's it's you get me you get pretty good
at it cuz you don't want that to be a
long drag don't think anybody else on
the team married with kids yeah actually
I don't know about kids they we have an
offensive lineman who is the one of my
favorite people just the happiest guy
ever Mike Brown they came in and he
actually just got married
other than that I think we got a guy on
the defensive line that's engaged not
married yet
Crawford last year had two kids but he's
gone now so there's some guys that have
been similar situations first games
Tennessee how the Mountaineer is looking
we're looking alright man just uh you
know we got we got some talented guys
got some experience got a got some work
to do and gotta keep pushing forward but
I like this team I think we're a close
team I think that we got good leadership
and we you know it's it's you know our
job as leaders to make sure that we stay
consistent every day and you know figure
out a way to win football games because
no matter how talented you are if you're
not winning so we got to figure out a
way to come together and win all sides
of the ball and win games what's your
major I graduated with a MDS major last
year what is that
multidisciplinary Studies well what are
you gonna do with that so it's it's uh
it's actually it's a it's three
different kind of majors you can get
into so I did communications journalism
and psychology and I have a minor in all
three and basically have a semester less
in each if I want to major in any of
them but you get a degree for doing a
minor in each then three different court
and three different uh majors he's will
Greer West Virginia quarterback joining
us Dan Patrick show who was who did you
look up to idolized model your game
after growing up Wow couple different
guys so I used to when I
first started playing it was when you
know Michael Vick was playing for the
Falcons which was in the NFC South and I
was growing up watching Panthers game so
I'd see them play the Panthers and stuff
and I was amazed by what he could do on
the football field I think he's one of
the greatest talents to ever play the
game and then growing up you know I
watched Peyton in his prime and
obviously Tom Brady is still doing what
he's doing and just you know I don't
think I think it was kind of a mixture
of people I've seen a lot of good
quarterbacks play and you know I don't
think I tried to model my game after one
in particular but tried to take
something from a couple different guys
and be my own guy obviously the talent
stood out but what stood out even more
with you was your hair the evolution of
the hair used to be long and there was a
party in the back now it looks like it's
all business here we'll talk about the
evolution of your hair break it down if
you can please so ya know I kind of just
didn't cut it for a while it just was
you know working before the year like
before the season started last year just
was focused on ball and didn't really
have time or care really enough to cut
it and just was letting to go and my
brother was letting his hair still
growing and got into the season and
everybody kind of you know liked it and
it became sort of my thing so I went
with it and then after the season I mean
I I didn't really like how it looked to
be completely honest but you know it so
after the season I was I was ready to
ready to cut it all off and and take a
take on a cleaner look so did that and
feel a lot better now well you got to
look like a Heisman candidate here we'll
so you got to factor that in did your
wife play a role in this um yeah
somewhat she was ready she was ready for
a new look yeah I get it have you done a
Heisman pose yet I have not will you
unless I win it oh that's the only time
you'll pose
yeah yeah maybe teach your daughter how
to do the Heisman pose I said I'll try
she doesn't she won't she's hilarious
man if I can get her sit still for a
little bit listen to me I'll try it
easier good luck with that by the way
but do you read this you know can't help
but get to your head a little bit that
you're you know one of the top Heisman
candidates at least preseason obviously
and maybe the first quarterback taken in
the draft how do you how do you absorb
that or how do you brush it to the side
yeah I think it's uh you know that's
obviously your great-great honors and
you know it'd be and of something those
are very prestigious things were talking
about but I mean those things will take
care of themself if I if I do my job for
this team so I put my focus and my
attention into making this team the best
I can and being a leader and you know
trying to just win games for for West
Virginia and you know that kind of stuff
is you know will take care of itself
towards the end of the year yeah there
you go that's the answer you're gonna be
given all season long probably with that
that question there so hey good luck
with raising your daughter obviously and
against Tennessee opening the season we
appreciate your time thank you will
thank you thank you from me that's will
Grier West Virginia quarterback for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]